i wonder how many cars they wrecked
shooting all the fast and furious movies
i think we've wrecked more cars than any
other franchise on the planet
hi i'm dennis mccarthy head of vehicles
for the fast and furious franchise i'm
here today to answer your questions on
twitter this is car support
[Music]
so bullseye bub has a question bro how
many gears do the cars and fast and
furious have
dude's been shifting like 20 times
shifting always makes
the scene a little bit more exciting and
for the most part it should match what
you're seeing on the screen
yes there's been a few straight line
drag races where the amount of gear
changes might exceed the transmissions
available gears but hey you know makes
for a good scene
now if you look closely at some of the
cars we've built for the movie i
represent them
as a six-speed a good good example that
would be the dodge daytona
in fast six and it was a six-speed car
we put a manual six-speed in the car
and you know my thought was that was a
modified car it wasn't like a restored
classic
we can do whatever we want you know it
helps that
somatically because you can see the guy
shifting gears oh well he has a six feet
no wonder he can keep going
in fast eight when we were in cuba we
built i think 10 of those 50 52 chevy's
and the scene is he's at the end of the
race their max speed the car spins
around
and he's going backwards so the first
thing that every car guy goes is man
that's impossible man reverse is like
first gear you can't go that fast
if you look at the interior of the car
you'll see there's two shifters in that
car
why because he took it out of a tractor
it's cuba you gotta make do with what
you have you need a transmission you're
not gonna go down to the store and buy
one
you're going to have to make something
you're going to have to find something
in this case you took the trans out of a
tractor so it had four forward gears
and it had four reverse gears and when
you watch him slide he comes around and
he's moving two sticks
one of those things you probably have to
watch in slow motion because i honestly
can't even remember if it all got
featured the way i dreamed it up but i
feel it's my responsibility to
make it look realistic and make it
explainable obviously that's a challenge
but uh you know i always do my best
at carol j s roth what's the coolest car
ever made
bonus points for picks you know there's
you know an endless list of cars that i
love
at least in my history in my lifetime
what's the coolest car and this is
actually before my lifetime but
close in the same decade would be the
chrysler turbine car now why is it cool
doesn't look that great it's a little
awkward looking has these you know
strange body lines but you know it was
turbine power so i'm going to give that
credit for being one of the coolest cars
ever maybe we move forward a couple
years
i'm going to give some credit to the 427
cobra why because it just had a
ridiculous amount of horsepower and a
very small car
behind me is one of my daily drivers
it's a hellcat powered six-speed charger
so today when i drive at home that'll be
my favorite coolest car of the day it's
just one of those things that's always a
fluid uh
a fluid answer um oomsa
watching the first two fast and furious
movies made me wonder
how did it get from what it was to what
it is now
the goal is always to top what we did
previously
every film we try to get bigger better
just to raise that excitement level to
raise the carnage factor which is one of
the things that i truly love
i don't know how it's even possible at
this point to top what we did in fast
nine but i say that on every movie
but somehow fast 10 will succeed at
corey duke
i may be coming into some money so if
you don't mind
what's the best kind of car to buy to
make up for a douchey
personality well i'm sorry to hear that
you can't be that big of a douche
because if you were you would never
admit to it so i'll give you some credit
there this is a very broad question i
don't know what your car needs are is it
a two-door do you have family do you
have people in the backseat you have to
tow something
there's so many variables there but i
would say whatever category
you're digging into just get the one
that has the most performance and the
best
horsepower numbers and you won't be a
douche anymore
at llsc underscore footballista
i wonder how many cars they wreck
shooting all the fast and furious movies
i mean if you
factor in you know two 300 a movie
you're probably in that ballpark
but i guess the bottom line is i think
we've wrecked more cars than any other
franchise on the planet
i think that's one of the elements that
makes these movies so great fast five
with the vault was probably
the number one carnage fest of the
franchise i mean it was just
day after day after day we shot a lot of
that sequence in
puerto rico and the puerto rican
government was kind enough to give us
access to this huge
surplus of government vehicles that were
out of service
so we basically had an endless supply of
cars to destroy
i think we were paying a dollar a car
was the deal we made
it was just one of those things that
really helped the cause i mean hey let's
do it one more time let's do it two more
times hey let's double the amount of
cars we just
we just had an endless supply of cars at
dre bay bay
every time i'm next to an 18-wheeler i
can't help but think of the scene fast
and furious
how do they manage to drive under it if
we go back to fast one
you have the truck driving it looks like
a normal truck you have the honda
swarming around it
all of a sudden the car swoops
underneath it that was accomplished by a
hydraulic system in that trailer that
would actually raise the trailer up
allowing just enough room for that honor
to swipe underneath the trailer
fast forward to fast seven we felt hey
this is a good time to bring it back
we've got
the gtr we've got a truck and trailer
let's redo that one so
this time we built a special trailer had
a little more clearance than your normal
trailer
and we actually installed a air system
in the gtr where the touch of a switch
the car would drop about three inches
and allow about a quarter inch of
clearance as the car
made its move underneath the trailer i
lied personally the fast 7 method
because basically
what occurred on film is exactly how we
did the gag so there was no altering
there was no raising or lower in the
trailer
you know two different films same gag
done differently but
same end result at maddie a19 dad tried
to explain carnage to me and i have
never felt that dumb in my whole life
car engines um i mean there's so many
different types of motors there's rotary
motors there's two stroke motors there's
four stroke motors four stroke piston
engines being the most common so let's
talk about the four strokes of the motor
you have intake compression power
exhaust the first stroke being the
intake stroke the intake stroke
the piston goes down so when that piston
drops
it creates a vacuum in this cylinder
this vacuum will pull air and fuel into
the motor
piston comes up compresses that air and
fuel gets right to the top
a spark plug ignites exploding that air
in fuel that force of that explosion
forces the piston down last step exhaust
valve opens
piston travels up it forces that spent
burnt gases out your exhaust pipe
down into the atmosphere hopefully you
understand how the piston goes up and
down now
that piston going up and down changes
the up and down force into a rotating
force the crankshaft rotates
the crankshaft goes to the transmission
the transmission will keep your
motor in the proper power band at
different speeds
you take off from the light your first
gear you got a second gear you got a
third gear
if it's a fast and furious movie you go
all the way up to like 16th or 17th gear
and that's how you get down the road
hopefully that helped without making you
feel down that awkward
duck what's the most ridiculous or over
the top
moment in any of the fast franchise
movies
i don't know if i want to say ridiculous
because you know it's all it's all for a
reason
if we want to go to over the top i would
say probably
the lycan building to building to
building jump
pops into my mind as probably one of the
most over-the-top
gags we've ever performed
you know what a lot of people don't know
is we actually did
toss a liking out of a building to clear
the gap and make it to the next building
that we might have
might have fudged that just a little bit
but nonetheless there was a complete set
built that was the interior of the first
building
and then there was a next year with the
glass and
a very substantial drop and then there
was even a crane involved to really get
that
crop speed that elevation up even higher
that was just one where i read the
script and i went
whoa okay you know here we go somehow
some way it actually
it actually sells from atlanta
binkley i accidentally asked my husband
if a supercharged
engine was better than a turbo and now
we're in a 20-minute deep convo
i stopped blissing after 30 seconds i
don't blame you because
there really is no good answer for that
one you know this is a battle that's
been going on for for decades and
decades and decades and there's a great
argument
on both sides the one big argument for
the turbo guys
is that they will say turbochargers are
free horsepower why is it free well it's
free because
you're not using the crankshaft to spin
anything you're actually taking the
exhaust
the exhaust is blowing on a small fan
that fan is connected to a shaft
that shaft has another fan they're
insulated in between
so now you have a fan that's spinning
and it just spins because of the exhaust
this fan can suck air in and pressurize
the motor creating boost
so that's where you hear the term
turbochargers are free horsepower
now a supercharger really is the same
concept is pressurizing the motor it's
forcing air and fuel into the motor
but it uses a belt and a crank off the
crankshaft so the crankshaft spins
spins a supercharger forces air why is
the belt bad what's the negative well it
draws horsepower like turning your air
conditioner you turn your ac
on it takes power to spin that ac
compressor
okay same thing goes for the
supercharger the bigger the blower
the more horsepower it absorbs to spin
the payoff's always better you're using
more power to get it all done
in the end you can really get the same
result the hellcat charger behind me is
a great example
supercharged car and nowadays the
technology is there
to make that a very drivable and
efficient machine
i don't have the answer on what's better
or worse i guess the next time you're at
the drag strip or watching some racing
you know see what people are running and
that will uh maybe help solve the
argument
this is from at basically ideal work
that's good it's always good to do some
work what do they do with all the
wrecked cars and the fast and furious
movies and how do i get one the real
answer is you probably don't you know i
mean the thing is
we usually wreck these cars once we
wreck them they don't just go to waste
we will recycle them we will use parts
off of that red car to keep another car
going
we might cut the car up for interior
shots i mean they really
by the time we're finished there's very
little left so at the end what we really
do is we just
scrap those cars there's nothing really
left on them that's worth anything so
they go right to the junkyard
they're crushed and then the ones that
are not wrecked
end up in universal's inventory or at
the theme parks for a little bit of an
afterlife
at b-reel if you had a choice between a
low rider and a muscle car
which would you choose i will say that
i've seen some of the highest
quality workmanship in low riders i mean
these cars frequently are painted
underneath everything's chrome there's
pinstriping underneath nowadays there's
billet parts machine parts cnc
stuff you know in my mind when i think
of a low rider though i think it's
something that you're going really slow
and you're just kind of cruising since i
like to drive fast i'm going to say
i like muscle cars because they're
typically built
to go fast so both have their place both
are extremely cool but yep i have uh
several muscle cars i don't own any low
riders but i have a lot of friends that
do
at rob bloggin the age-old question
what's the difference between power
beam horsepower and torque explained so
we can all understand
so this is a great question it's not an
easy question
and you can get very complex with
mathematical equations
the history of it how it came to be i'm
going to just explain it to you in very
simple forms
torque is really the relationship
between leverage
and a twisting force so going back to
the four strokes of the motor
the piston is forced down as the piston
is forced down it's forced down on a
crankshaft
so as that piston is forcing down
pressure on the connecting rod which is
forcing pressure onto the
crankshaft you're applying torque right
here
if you make the stroke of the crankshaft
longer you'll get more torque
shorter you're going to lose torque but
you'll be able to gain rpm
the simple answer is big truck towing
weight you want lots of torque
you know high revving car you want lots
of horsepower
the way you make up for the lack of
torque on a high horsepower car is
gearing
at shillary fox i wonder how much gas a
fast and furious car
needs vroom vroom i want one that
depends on the car it depends on what
we're doing
you know there's some cars that we've
built that use a tremendous amount of
fuel there's other cars that we built
that are you know
fairly good on the fuel consumption
they're about like your normal hot rod
your normal race car
we've built a few cars in the past that
really did suck a lot of fuel
one that comes to mind would be the
heist truck and fast fire that steals
the vehicles off the train
that had a 500 plus inch v8 motor in it
it was a very heavy vehicle
somewhere around 7000 pounds giant tires
and what really sucked the fuel down was
a terrain we were in very soft sand
so running a truck in soft sand that's
heavy with big tires
i think we were getting around one and a
half miles per gallon but then like i
said we can take a
you know a twin turbo gtr and that car
even under stunt driving
might still get you know 15 18 miles per
gallon
anytime we're on location we film in
some very very remote and exotic
locations like iceland for instance we
were in the middle of nowhere i think
the nearest gas station was 50 miles
away
so we always bring our own fuel truck
how much fuel we bring depends on
what cars we're working with and how far
we are from the nearest gas station so
always something you don't want to run
out of at michelle cold tw
what is the point of car spoilers so on
your street car there's really no point
other than cosmetic it just they look
cool
you know that's really why you see cars
around the street with big wings and big
spoilers
now if you're going 130 140 you're
at a racetrack you're in a drag race
they're very important
spoilers are kind of slang i mean it can
refer to a wing on the back and refer to
a
spoiler up on the front of the car the
real goal is to keep the car on the
ground if you would have a larger
front spoiler that would have provided
down force on the front of the car kept
the front of the car
glued to the ground not let that air get
underneath it and lift the car
up over backwards so that's really the
purpose of the front player is keep the
downforce keep the car on the ground
keep
the air from getting turbulent
underneath the car as far as the rear
spoiler or rear wing
that is to keep downforce really on the
back tires for traction mostly
so street car not really a big factor
race cars whether it's nascar
indy car f1 racing you know bonneville
salt flat stuff
very important for getting to the front
or keeping the speed and safety to keep
your car from
blowing over backwards anyways good
question fully
vaccinated click erisa at
fatto thought for
20. okay a lot can be read into that
whole title there
what's the difference between diesel and
gas and why can't it go
in the same engine the main difference
between the diesel and gas motor
there's no spark plug air fuel
compressed
spark that's what gets you going down
the road diesel is a little bit
different
diesel requires heat and pressure same
concept
same four strokes but the piston comes
up it's compressing the diesel and the
air
but much higher pressure than a gasoline
motor
and it's that pressure and the heat that
actually ignites it
forcing the piston down if you put
gasoline in a diesel
it can destroy the motor it can
absolutely just you know you're pulling
the motor out you're putting another one
in it if you put diesel in a gas motor
it usually doesn't destroy it
but that's going to do is avoid that
altogether at lee
i'm gonna say ski somebody stole my
boyfriend's driveshaft in the middle of
night
begging the question what is a
driveshaft and why is it more valuable
than diamonds
well i'd probably rather have the
diamonds in the dry shaft but let's talk
about
first what it does the drive shaft
basically transfers power from the
transmission
to the rear end if you have a front
wheel drive car it's going to be a cv
axle
rear wheel drive all-wheel drive car
you're going to have some drive shafts
now
why is it valuable it's really not that
valuable so
whoever stole it had to have had the
exact same car
because that's not a common thing i
think if i were you and your boyfriend
i'd be driving around the neighborhood
i'd be looking for a car just like yours
that maybe had some performance mods
where
the guy applied too much power and broke
his drive shaft but it's probably
someone close to you with the same car
that took it
and i would say the value of a
driveshaft is anywhere between you know
400 and 1200 dollars so
i hope you find it okay we have spot
blots writing in why
is the transmission of my 95 mitsubishi
eclipse automatic slipping well you made
a
terrible mistake and you should have
bought the manual with trans there's
just something that's not right about a
95 eclipse with an automatic
you know they should all been manual
transmissions and problem would
have never occurred hey kyra dickens how
do you go full
speed and even over the speed limit when
it's pouring what kind of tires you have
because if i tried that i'd be spinning
into oncoming traffic first off
don't speed when it's pouring that's
probably the you know the
common sense uh answer that but
definitely don't go over the speed limit
and if you are driving fast in the rain
make sure you do have the proper tires
the tire that's designed for the rain
will have
basically different grooving in it maybe
more grooving deeper grooving it's
designed to shed the water away from the
tire and out the sides
the last thing you want to do is drive
in the rain at any kind of speed with
ball
tires or slicks or anything along those
lines
that's why if you ever watch a nascar
race as soon as you start
seeing some raindrops on the windshield
that's it caution's out we're done
racing we're gonna wait for it to dry
the track has to get dried why
because the slicks have zero traction in
the rain in wet
weather they just don't work now you go
to uh f1 racing
and i wish that all forms of racing
would follow this lead when it rains
they don't stop the race
they change their tires they put their
rain tires on and they get back out
there
there's definitely a skill level with
driving in the rain
it's similar to drifting like if you're
a good drifter odds are going to be
great at driving in the rain
some of you should do cautiously closed
track is a good
place to start that practice and you'll
see it's really
all about the tires and your level of
skill use caution
at car news updates how exactly does
dominic tereto
blow his engine on his charger in the
fast and furious during the railroad
drag
i wasn't really involved in that movie
but i'm going to do my very best to
answer the question for you
so if you watch that race they're neck
and neck they're both given and
everything they've got
i'm going to say his car either burned a
hole through a piston or a broke a
piston ring because all of a sudden
everything starts going haywire he's
losing power
you start seeing smoke there's smoke
coming out from under the car so that's
typically a catastrophic failure so the
question is
well how does he continue to go so fast
well you know he has an eight cylinder
so maybe he lost one cylinder he still
has seven left and he has a ton of boost
being fed by a supercharger
into that motor so even though
something's failed
maybe that piston is now only half as
powerful as it should be
but it's still making power it's still
gonna get the car down the track that's
my
best explanation on it at joseph3
jacobo don't get the point of people
revving your engine
like what's the purpose of it good
question and i
totally agree with it there is no point
there's nothing more annoying than some
guy sitting there at the light revving
his engine 20 times
it does nothing so uh yeah i think it'd
be better if you want to seem less
douchey
don't sit there revving your motor one
of the worst things you can ever do is
start your car up when it's cold
and the oil hasn't warmed up and
circulated to the motor and you start
revving your motor that's how you can
actually really do some damage
just going off this photo this is from
the joker watching the end of fast and
furious six
oh my god how long is that runway it's a
great question i think the math
when you calculate speed time distance
comes out to be about 26 miles long so
it is a
very very long runway luckily for us
because we had a lot of action going on
we actually were on an airport out in uh
northern north of london it was like a
three hour drive it was a remote
location
i want to say it was like a military
basis it wasn't like an airport that was
open to the public but cool place it was
huge and i don't know how long it was
but it was probably
two and a half miles so it was three
miles i mean when you stood there and
looked down and you couldn't see you
know it looked like you were on 26 miles
but yeah that one did stretch out a
little a little long but
car ride chili at t chili 14.
i just saw the stunts from the new fast
and furious and how the
they be coming up with that like that
look hard shouldn't they be out of ideas
somebody to rephrase that or no sorry if
i offended anybody with that one but
just read them as they come in
it's really a group effort to come up
with the greatest action sequences
ever seen on film and that's what we
strive for and there's a lot of time
that goes into this
it's not like you know there's boom boom
boom let's let's write the script let's
do it
scripts written everybody talks about it
discusses it
there's testing done there's practicing
down there's we wreck a lot of cars
before we even get the film
just trying to figure out the best way
to do things could be someone from the
construction department or special
effects said hey i got a great way or i
you know i thought of something and
everyone's opinion gets you know
brought into the conversation and you
know sometimes it goes nowhere
sometimes it's hey that's brilliant
let's let's do that i think when you
have that type of mindset when you're
you know creating something like a fast
and furious movie it really just leads
to a better final product
thoughts on all your questions hopefully
i you know gave you some insight
of some information of some sort i hope
thank you all have a great day